The answer is it only helps us if we know something else about K.
The reason for this is if K is uniformly distributed,
and we're XORing it with these other values,
whatever patterns that M and S have are lost when they get XORed with K.
This is the whole point of the one-time pad that we can
XOR a random key with a message and hide all the statistical properties in the message.
This is not the case that it helps us by itself.
If this was all we knew this is a potentially interesting property,
but we need to know something more in order to use this to help break the cipher.
Knowing something more about M would be great.
That's the message we're trying to decrypt, but that's separate from being able to use
this property in a useful way.
What we really need to do is know something more about K.